was it i'm always going to be in this
shadow or was it i want to make him
proud was it i still have his genes was
it we're destined to do something big
like what because in most instances like
that it's more like yeah i'm just going
to be his son versus
to to come and create your own identity
with that kind of a shadow that's not
easy to do completely and i he always he
made it very very clear my father was
also quite a morbid man
i think because of his life even in his
last years he spoke all the time about
he had conversations which were you'd be
sitting at the table and he said are you
prepared for my death
and you just be like well
is that a will and testament what are
you talking about like are you prepared
like he'd talk about dying he'd talk
about me being the oldest son he'd talk
about me having to carry the torch he
talked about how did he start doing that
at what age
when i was young 19 20. got it quite
young
he died october 17 2015. correct so
you're saying 19 so that would be your
35 25 so 16 years ago 2006. yeah so 10
years before he passed away he's talking
to you that way he's talking about death
he's talking about what that's going to
mean he's talking about how i have to
carry the family torch he's talking
about my responsibilities and duties
he's talking about the fact that i need
to evolve and be a better version of him
he talked about these things a lot
now he also used to he to till the day i
was an adult he still had a superior
complex over me and i i respect it my
dad used to say things like oh you're
champion
[Laughter]
cause you know you're right
so that's just how he was as an
individual but um
i i think it's the opposite he set such
a high standard in certain regards
that
i knew i couldn't just be some normal
guy
i'd feel guilt
i'd feel dirty if i was just some normal
dude like i can't just be i'm his son
you know like in the old movies when you
watch conan they say
tate the son of did uh i was always the
son of emory tate even at the chess
tournaments it's the son of tate the sun
up the sun up the sun up the expectation
was there and instead of it
preventing me from creating my identity
i was actually the opposite okay i have
to be fantastic and i was cerebral
enough i said to my dad look i can't be
as good at chess as you can i don't
think i can do this and they say well
you could
but belief is a huge part of it so if
you don't believe you can then what else
are you going to do
because i remember telling him i didn't
want to play chess anymore he said
that's fine but you're not going to not
play chess and [ __ ] watch tv
you play chess for six hours a day so
you need to come to me with a plan for
six hours a day so what are you going to
do with your life
and i chose fighting because i said
listen chess is one-on-one competition
without luck without a team
no ball no win to blow the ball on the
net what if i fight
he said okay i respect that you can be a
fighter so it was he wasn't trying to
force me to do anything but he was he
was very regimented individual and
that's who he was and i had so much
respect for him and he was my superhero
i wanted to be like my dad and even from
a very young age they even if you were
to google up my dad emory tate and look
in the chess community they called him
e.t for every tape also e.t like the
alien because he was a bit strange but
the way he played chess was so
unorthodox
that sometimes he had some spectacular
losses but sometimes he had some
spectacular victories against some of
the top players in the world so everyone
was scared of him because he played with
such recklessness
that he was like all is blitzkrieg if
you get through it you survive you get
to beat him but when it's coming hard
and the heat's on he destroyed some
grand masters so badly that they took
like a year away from tournaments like
genuine like embarrassment that's how he
played so nobody wanted to play my
father because it was a risk right
because he's only taught 200 in the
world but he's smoking top 10 sometimes
he loses but sometimes he'll [ __ ]
take your head off so he was an anomaly
so whenever i went to a chess tournament
they're like tate's here takes you
there's always the rumbles and not tapes
here
things so the name was always feared
and i think that was part of it for me i
i wanted when i when i turned up to a
fight event tates here takes it i want
my name to mean something right i wanted
to mean something like and and that was
always very important to me and i was
just told look you want your name to
matter then you have to go make it
matter it's not going to matter by
default
and if you have good parents
um and and i was and and some hardship
and some trauma i think any man can
become anything they want to be if you
enjoyed this video and you want to watch
the entire podcast click over here and
if you want to be connected with experts
influencers such as kiyosaki tate
connolly palmeteri myself and others
download the app minect where you get a
chance to connect with these folks by
the minute you get to buy the minute or
have face times with them 15 minutes ask
them any questions you may want to have
download the admin act and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]